hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his work fear and trembling sir and
Kierkegaard we'll make a set of
scattered remarks that occur early on
midway through and at the very end of
his work and they have to do with a very
important topic one that not only is
found in his works as a whole but also
in other existentialist thinkers and
other philosophical attitudes and
perspectives and it has to do with
several different ideas that are that
are coming together one is what he's
calling the present generation and of
course he's talking about a generation
that's long since dead including himself
but what he's telling us applies to us
in the present and would seem to apply
to any generations yet to come
and then it also has to do with the work
of the spirit and if the word spirit is
turning you off here because you think
it's a little too theological think mind
think heart think what makes us
distinctively human and what we'll get
into that in just a moment and I thought
it would be good to begin by looking at
a very short passage in which
Kierkegaard is talking about the figure
of Abraham so somebody who's long long
ago passed away but who is the main
figure the hero if you like of fear and
trembling and he asks what is the value
of going to the trouble of remembering
that past which cannot become a present
now what does this mean in terms of
Abraham we can remember his past we can
you know largely get this from the
Genesis story in which Abraham actually
occupies a significant portion of that
biblical text but it's just outlines for
the most part about a number of
different things that happen in
Abraham's life and of course we're not
going to go back to ancient Mesopotamia
as a live option
for ourselves hear the call of God
telling us to leave our city life behind
and move out into the wilderness we're
not going to become a clan chieftain
we're not going to engage in
circumcision with a stone knife of all
sorts of people who are following us
those are not parts of this what he's
talking about here the becoming becoming
a present for us what are we talking
about then well this book is about what
Kierkegaard is terming faith and we'll
talk about this in other lectures faith
for Kierkegaard means something a bit
different than just blind assent or a
deficient form of you know pseudo
knowledge the way that a lot of people
construe it today it means a fundamental
attitude and we can in fact grasp
through the example of Abraham if not
faith itself at least what it must be
like to be living with faith and that's
not an easy thing as a sort of side note
here Kierkegaard says that faith is
going to involve anxiety distress
paradox so it's not a nice resolution
but this is something that we could in
fact make a live possibility for ourself
in whatever present we live within and
this has in fact been the case for those
following in the footsteps of Abraham
whether it be in the Middle Ages or in
the ancient period or in the you know
the Renaissance and the Reformation even
if we imagine 500 years from today
this is a live possibility and now you
could say well there is some value in
going to a past which cannot become a
present we do history this way history
is valuable and interesting Kierkegaard
is interested in sort of our existential
commitments and orientation and life so
when we're looking at past figures we
want to know is what's really essential
in their attitude towards life towards
the higher things
towards everything else is that
available for us in the present now
let's go on in the preliminary
expectoration before the probe LaMotta
in fear and trembling he tells us that
there's a distinction between the
external world of the visible world and
the world of the spirit now what does he
mean by the world of the spirit I
mentioned if you have a problem with the
world with a word spirit just you know
substitute mind or heart or the core of
your person what is truly essential to
you as a human being and then there's
all these extra things you know this
shirt I don't have to be wearing this
shirt this is something external much of
what we focus on in our lives is indeed
external and he says there's a paradox
here from the external invisible world
there's a funny adage only he who works
gets bread they says this is completely
false that's not the case at all there's
all sorts of people who don't do a lick
of work and they get fed and they don't
just get bread they get all sorts of
sumptuous banquets and there's plenty of
people who work and work their fingers
to the bone and they don't get anything
out of it they're exploited they're
dominated they are taken advantage of so
what is the case for this external
visible world she says in the external
world everything belongs to the
possessor it's subject to the law as he
says of indifference and the spirit of
the ring obeys the one who has the ring
he's talking about a lad and there and
he says whoever has the wealth of the
world has it regardless of how he got it
so you know some people are born with
certain aptitudes one of those aptitudes
could be as we joke around being born
into a wealthy family you know why
didn't you pick wealthier parents for
your parents when you were born silly
question right there's so much that is
not really up to us and then is unfair
and the world works that way is it that
way in the life of the Spirit is it that
way in the life of the mind now you
might say of course it is because who
gets to go to Harvard or the Sorbonne or
the Ecole Normale or to you know Oxford
or pick any of these other prestigious
places well you know ideally anybody can
go right if you're smart enough you can
get a scholarship there's some truth to
that but there's also a lot of falsity
to that as well and the fortunate thing
is that it doesn't actually work this
way in the life of the mind or the
spirit or the heart he says here an
eternal divine order prevails it does
not reign on both the just and the
unjust here the Sun does not shine on
the good and the evil here it holds true
that only the one who works gets bread
and then he goes on with a few other
things as well but let's focus on the
bread thing for just a moment unless you
actually put in the work you don't get
the benefits you can take as many
shortcuts as you like but they turn out
not to be shortcuts because they don't
get you across the distance to the place
you want to go to if you want to
understand Kierkegaard this video that
or a lecture or any other thing can be
extremely useful for you but sooner or
later you've got to actually read
Kierkegaard and engage with that in your
own mind in a sort of dialogue with the
author or you're not going to understand
Kierkegaard doesn't matter how many
glosses sparknotes
podcast videos whatever resources you
use unless you're actually engaging with
the text you don't actually know it
unless you are willing to spend the time
not just to speed read through it or to
skim it once but to actually go through
it until you understand you're not going
to get that bread
he goes on and he says only the one who
is in anxiety finds rest only the one
who descends into the lower world
rescues the beloved the Aries referring
to the Orpheus story only the one who
draws the knife gets Isaac there he's
referring to the Abraham story what
happens if you don't do that he who will
not work does not get bread but is
deceived just as the gods deceived
Orpheus
deceived him because he was soft not
boldly braved and he says here it
doesn't help to have Abraham as a father
or to have seventeen ancestors the one
who will not work is not going to get
anything and it doesn't matter what
pedigree you have it doesn't matter what
school you went to it doesn't matter
what golden opportunities you've been
given it doesn't matter what scholarship
you're on it doesn't matter how many
followers you have on Facebook or
Twitter or anything you could just be
full of wind as Kierkegaard says here
and your works could be nothing if you
are not actually willing to put in the
labor required so the same thing goes
for understanding Abraham here we have
to work not just possess right or
inherent another thing that he's going
to talk about that's tied in with this
it comes a little bit later and in the
work is this notion of taking faith as a
starting point now here we're not just
talking about an individual who is
fortunate enough to start with a leg up
as we say or even in the proverbial
silver spoon in their mouth we're
talking about cultural development and
one generation coming after another
particularly in terms of the life of the
mind that of a philosophy and of
religion in this case many people in
Kierkegaard's own time we're saying
faith you know that's something great
for the middle ages and dumb peasants
out in the countryside but for the rest
of us cultivated people we have
philosophy and philosophy can begin
with this crude rude starting point of
faith and then clarify its conceptions
and purify them of their their dross
their chaff all the stuff that we want
to leave behind we can take what
religion was offering and refine it
Kierkegaard is saying unless you
actually grasp faith to begin with and
that may be the work of a lifetime
you're really working off of a fake
starting point
you don't actually understand what
you're proceeding from and we see so
many people like this again to use the
example of our contemporary media just
because you read a Wikipedia article on
something or a sparknotes
or watch a video or watch you know a
documentary does not mean that you
actually understand what it is that
you're talking about with the sort of
thoroughness that would be required for
you to transcend it to go beyond it to
make progress towards something else and
there may be many things where we have
to experience that existentially
experientially throwing ourselves into
it or we really can't talk about it
competently so one key challenge for our
age getting past this illusion of taking
faith as a starting point rather than
something that we're trying to
understand and proceed to the last thing
that I want to bring up in this this set
of issues that's also connected with it
is this problem that he discusses in the
epilogue the problem of
intergenerational learning and he says
what ten generations learn from each
other it's a wonderful passage he says
whatever one generation learns from
another no generation learns the
essentially human from a previous one in
this respect each generation begins
primitively
and we'll come back to that in a moment
because we need to make a very
important distinction here if we say no
generation learns anything from the
previous generation they have to
completely begin from the point a and
move on well that's nonsense because the
whole of human culture is passing on
from one generation to the next and
inheritance that we can take up and do
something with the you know the fact
that we have books in the first place
that Kierkegaard who's been dead over a
century is available and accessible to
us here in these books is an example of
that Kierkegaard himself wrote in Danish
this is an English translation somebody
else the Hong's took up his work and
provided it for us the technology that
you're you're contacting me at a
distance through at this very moment
whether it be video or podcast or blog
or whatever it happens to be is part of
that as well
generations do provide something else to
the following generation that they can
pick up and use the key difference here
is when it comes to what tier two guard
has said is essentially human so let's
look at this passage a little bit more
he says each generation begins
primitively
has no other task other than what each
previous generation had nor does it
advance further insofar as the previous
generations did not betray the task and
deceive themselves so he uses the
example of love all of us have to learn
what it means experientially to love
does that mean that we can't benefit
from the advice of older people does
that mean that we can't look back to
Aristotle and read his classic treatise
on friendship in nikka mckay and ethics
books eight and nine and benefit from
that as well no it doesn't mean that but
it also means that we ourselves as each
generation have to figure these things
out for ourselves have
orient ourselves within them and there's
no possible substitute for that so he
goes on and he says the essentially
humanist passion in passion he says one
generation perfectly understands another
and understands it stuff and this is
where he brings up love but he also
tells us the highest passion is faith
and so we cannot learn faith just by
getting ourselves a textbook or
purchasing a course or listening to
lectures we have to work at it we have
to appropriate it we have to take
ownership of it ourselves and this is in
fact you might say a creative process
and he says here no generation begins at
any other point than where the previous
one did each generation begins all over
again the next generation advances no
further than the previous one if that
one was actually faithful to its task
and didn't leave the generation coming
after them high and dry so what does
this mean for us again we at any given
moment in time have this this work ahead
of us if we want to understand what is
essentially human we have to do the work
involved in that we can't just have
somebody else do that work for us and we
can't get a leg up on how to do it by
belonging to a privileged class or going
to the right school or any of these
other shortcuts that people have for all
the other things in life and we have a
task as a generation to you might say
pass the ball but it's a ball that we
have to remake as we do it now that's
the bad news
nobody can do the work for us what's the
good news
none of us are behind it doesn't matter
that we come from whatever background
we do all of us have the possibility of
tapping into the same essentially human
as any other person whether they have
social prestige whether they be rich
whether they speak the right language
whether they have the right Missa tee
none of those things matter as far as
the life of the Spirit is concerned only
those who work gain the bread only those
who experience and do the work involved
in that experience and making sense of
it derive the knowledge or at least the
passion that is involved
you